[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
now today we're going to talk about the
ixians so in the Dune series The ixians
were the inhabitants of a fringe world
at the edge of the Empire called IX now
IX was the ninth planet in its solar
system and the world of IX unlike most
planets had escaped the harshest effects
of the butlerian Jihad so this means
they were much more okay with machine
technology and even some technology that
pushed the prescriptions of the
butlerian Jihad now if you're not
familiar with the butlerian Jihad then
I've done several videos on it which you
can find in my Dune playlist on my
channel essentially about 10 000 years
before the start of the Dune series
mankind relied on intelligent machines
for just about everything when the
butlerian Jihad happened all thinking
machines were banished from the Empire
and the line Thou shalt not make a
machine in the likeness of a human mind
was added to their orange Catholic Bible
which was a big religious text in the
Dune University so basically any
Computing technology was banned now the
thing about the ixians is it is not
extremely clear in what ways and at what
times they are actually defying the
butlerian Jihad but it is clear that
they are now when it comes to the danger
of ixian technology and the danger of
technology in general as it's presented
in the Dune Universe there are two ways
we are meant to think about this one way
is the danger of human dependency on
technology if we become too dependent on
technology then in a situation when we
don't have it Society might collapse the
other way we're meant to think about
this is the potential danger of the
exponential growth of that technology
itself now this is what leicho II feared
the most about the ixians and this is
one of the main things that he worked so
hard to undo and God Emperor it says do
not fear the ixians he's said he heard
his own voice as a fading whisper they
can make the machines but they can no
longer make arafel I know I was there
now we've talked about this line before
on this channel rfl refers to the cloud
darkness of holy judgment it's a
Biblical reference
essentially he's saying don't worry
about the ixians I have made it so that
they can never create the technology
that would destroy all of humanity now I
will say that the ixians will still
produce this technology these seeking
machines that siona Atreides herself
sees in the Visions but he has created a
way for Humanity not to be destroyed he
has created a way for Humanity to hide
now we all remember the scene in Dune
with the hunter Seeker device now
imagine a hunter Seeker device that so
finely tuned that not even a breath or
heartbeat can be hidden from it now
imagine that this device is also
self-replicating imagine that it reaches
a level of comprehension that resembles
prescience this is what leito foresaw a
machine that would seek out and hunt and
kill all humans until there were no more
humans this is the ixian problem this is
the Paradox of endless technological
innovation at some point eventually the
technology develops to a point where it
is beyond our control of it this ixian
dilemma is a mirror of the tleaksu
Dilemma the sleigh laksu are also
technological innovators On The Fringe
except they emphasize biological
technology their face dancer slave class
who they gradually improved again and
again throughout the eons eventually
grew far beyond their own control until
eventually they present themselves as
the god-like beings Daniel and Marty at
the end of the book Chapter House Dune
so when thinking about the ixian problem
and the talak suit problem it becomes
clear that at the heart of Doom has
always been this sort of warning about
the careless development of Technology
just for the sake of development it's
not saying don't innovate but it is
saying be mindful of where this could
potentially lead and it's also saying
that there need to be safe cards so that
like if it goes too far we can handle it
everybody wants a prescient
self-replicating Hunter Seeker device
until you can no longer control what it
is seeking out the thing about
technology is once it exists it can
never be put back in the box
think about nuclear weapons and how all
of humanity could be destroyed with just
the pressing of a few buttons once the
technology is created the cat is out of
the bag so to speak it is almost
impossible to stop technological
innovation humans seem to want to keep
improving upon things they build some of
you might have heard of the
technological singularity that's at the
core of this idea the technological
singularity is a hypothetical point in
time where technological growth will
become radically faster and
uncontrollable resulting in
unforeseeable changes to human
civilization the ixian problem is the
technological singularity the seeking
machines would be there the smell of
blood and entrails the cowering humans
in their Burrows aware only that they
could not Escape while all the time the
mechanical movement approached nearer
and nearer louder and louder everywhere
she searched it would be same No Escape
anywhere so Frank Herbert was concerned
about something that several authors
before him and an incredible amount of
authors after him were also concerned
about the technological singularity the
point in time where we lose control of
the technology that we are cultivating
and developing
if you look at the modern world and you
think of things like the YouTube
algorithm or Google the vast majority of
us have no idea how these things work
but there are also some programs which
are black boxes you put in input and it
gives you a result and no one
understands how it's getting the result
not even the programmers now of course
I'm not a computer scientist so I'm sure
it's a lot more complicated than that
but you can get my point essentially in
the Dune Saga Frank Herbert is making
the argument that we cannot stop
technological progress
but we can improve upon ourselves and
make it so that we are not so dependent
upon technology that our civilization
falls apart when it is not around and to
make sure we keep it in check so that it
does not get to a point where we cannot
control it and dial things back if they
get a little bit too intense if the AIS
start taking over the planet
alright thanks for watching guys what do
you think about these Concepts what are
some of your favorite science fiction
books that share similar Concepts let me
know in the comment section below just a
heads up for those of you that may be
interested my next graphic novel the LIE
behind the star is launching February
2023 you can sign up now to get on the
email mailing list to get notified as
soon as it launches more information on
my website link in the description thank
you guys so much
[Music]